yeah tell up to white kids talking to
each other remarkable
colen Stellar dude to go excellent
work take us to the
[Music]
topen welcome back to a highly essential
episode careful boys we have Anthony
right here we got regular Joe we got
regular Nick Colleen and the superior
Joseph Cool Joe over here
uh you may not have an example of this
but uh if you do I think it'd be really
helpful to share but uh was there ever a
time in your life
anywhere that you genuinely felt
excluded from something oh dude yeah in
high school what happened in high school
in high school in San Jose mhm what
happened was it what was what were you
like in high school um I was a
basketball player I did
track um but uh my school is
predominantly
Asian yes did that bum you out no no no
no push him in the corner pushing like
man I even got no I even got yellow
fever so no no no
hey was it cuz all of your teammates
were so short and you were just like man
I feel so left out I'm like the best
player in this [__] all you guys
suck I want to get dunked on too no I
felt like uh I don't know like for me I
don't really like
even like till this day like whenever I
go to like work or something like that
go to work come home and just chill I
like just being a home body I like just
chilling stuff like that relaxing um so
I felt like in in high school you know
all my phow freedom friends were like
get together go out eat and stuff like
that but I was never really like invited
but I was always like in the social
group to where it's like I was always
bouncing around between like this group
and this group and this group so I never
had like an actual like Core Group it
was just like me and probably like one
other friend and then we would just
bounce just be cool with every and just
be cool but yeah I kind of felt left out
because they would go do cool some like
cool stuff like outside of school
sometimes and then you know I wouldn't
be there damn that's pretty much about
that sounds pathetic n it's not really
that bad it's not really that bad it's
not really
that I tried to make it sound worse than
it was but you
know to somebody that does yeah like
people have experiences like that all
the time for sure for sure for I've
talked about this before too but like
you know kids are so [__] they're
such dicks when when you know we're all
young and stuff like that I remember uh
when I was at same thing if I was in
high school it's like I wasn't Korean
there's hell Korean people there so it's
like I'm clearly an outlier in that
group but then with the Chinese people
hell Chinese people I was like not fully
Chinese cuz I didn't speak Chinese so
that'd be like the Vietnamese of me I
had that with the black community it's
like I'm not dark enough to be black or
stuff like that so you never really
fully get in there you don't get invited
to certain stuff or then like in my
Vietnamese Boy Scout Troop that I was in
too the only problem was I was still
Chinese there not fully Vietnamese so
like you I was just constantly never
enough of something to be a part of I
feel like if you're mixed you have that
problem a lot too that's true so it took
me a long time thinking that my mixed
element was uh something that was a
hindrance and you know I metion here
before but it wasn't until I was like a
grown ass adult that I was like no this
is like my superpower you know I'm
whatever it is when I want it to be
[__] like this convenient for me
right now is what I am you know you
can't deny that so it I was definitely
excluded a lot did did they call that
out or it was just something that
happened people would call it out
they're like you're China boy you're
like you're not Chinese but you're
Vietnamese espe at that is sh that's how
I got the ancestry DNA test cuz you know
same thing same thing that's interesting
it is interesting too that like if you
were in sports like to somebody like me
if I was in your school I would just
think automatically you're cooler but
then I wouldn't even think a guy like
you would ever feel excluded I would
assume like like if me and like 10 other
Filipino guys my height was in next to
you in school and we went and did
something I would feel weird inviting
you cuz I would assume you wouldn't even
want to hang with this yeah I think that
was like a lot a lot of the things too
cuz I it it was High School is kind of
weird for me because like I never felt
like I was popular but I was popular as
[__] for some reason like I got
nominated for prom King I had two prom
dates like I two prom dates that's hey
that's that's a lot cooler than prom
King you asked out two girls and you got
two prom dates yeah I took two best
friends oh that's cool at the same time
at the same prom you took two so yeah
who's done that
before look at his face that's crazy
trying to put an extra Spotlight on you
because he was prom King
too and he took didn't have two dates
though yeah only had one date oh see
that's where you messed up bro and
that's I I wa but did you win prom King
though no yeah me neither it was some
person that was like part of yearbook
committee that knew when [__]
yearbook people dude nepotism
neptis we just misuse it every time they
have the inside scoop dude the [__]
yearbook people they're [__] they're
it's all inside dude they got they got
it all figure they're the ones that
control everything they put the yearbook
together true their photos are all up in
it I was inbook so I know yeah you're
right I didn't realize but what's crazy
I didn't realize like I was really that
popular and then when I graduated high
school I had a whole bunch of girls like
come up to me that were friends were
like yeah I thought you were like super
cute in high school this and that and
I'm just like why why didn't you tell me
why didn't you tell me then why did you
tell me now and I'm like all the way on
the other side of the stage like cuz you
got to fly back dud
hope you got
some got to fly these ladies out what
about you Nick has that ever happened to
you the only time I really felt like
excluded was by my own family dude no
for real um ex as a young kid though as
a young kid cuz you're the only guy well
kind of cuz they won't let you play
Princess yeah I want to be part of I
could be useful princess you could have
been playing Ken I could yeah but
actually no I can't play Ken it's weird
uh my sister my sisters were older than
me six or seven years apart and they
would they were like the Pod they were
they would be together they would do
everything together I'd always want to
come in and do stuff they're like get
out of here Nick I'd be like all right
I'd leave but I did teach me how to like
be by myself you know which was actually
a good thing though like it I kind of
like would play by myself I'd [__]
set things on fire by myself I would
destroy things in the house by myself
you know I I I'd write margarate on
things by myself you sound like a real
life Toy Story F no for yeah for real
yeah that's a good way of actually yeah
but yeah like I would just just do my
own thing and then learn how to play by
myself which was good I think but then
also as I got older it would always be
like my sisters and my parents just
having their own conversations about
everything and I'd just be like Yeah
okay or like if some if they get in an
argument and they start yelling I'd be
like hey you guys like just trying to
like stop yelling at each other and
they're just like shut the [__]
up [__] you Dad you piece of [__] and go
back I'll be like hey guys come on let's
let's try to lower our voices and we can
talk calmly with each other and they're
like shut up you always make your
parents look like Biff from like back
the [__] out of my car
man he's a sensible one no but seriously
they would look at me like like shut the
[__] up you know
um but it would just be things like that
but as I got older I would I realized
it's like oh yeah yeah it's like it's
it's just part of the age Gap it's it's
part of the Dynamics and the family of
like me being the youngest and I would
always just kind of keep my mouth shut
anyway and just be like listening um
right but yeah that's about it yeah
other than that it's like that's pretty
big though in your own home with your
family yeah but it it was a good thing
though I think it's a good thing I think
it's a it's a net positive overall just
because you know you just learn how to
figure it out you do come off with like
really good coping skills and like you
know oh okay thank you you could have
been playing with Barbies yeah oh I was
playing with
Barbies I was making on my girlfriend
dude he was handling the the subplot
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah plot B dude
most of my examples are people's parents
saying you can't play with them anymore
cuz I was a [__] Menace or Japanese I
thought it was cuz you're Japanese
too that was a big one the sleepover one
where you're like you can't you can't
sleep over that was the that was one cuz
you're Japanese and yeah the but the
other one was like I was playing with
this uh my friend's my friend his dad's
a pastor yeah and I guess like his mom
was like oh he's a bad influence so it
was going to look bad on her family you
might know them too they they used to be
the church lalin church oh yeah and they
told my mom and stuff and I was just
like we're just friends isn't is doesn't
it make more sense for what you do
though kind what kind of things did they
know that you did that would define you
as a bad no this is before I was
actually doing like bad [__] like I was
just a kid like I was like 10 so like 10
and under they're just I was just a
[__] Menace I guess oh you were just
like uh like you just running around too
much breaking [__] and then we just have
so much fun that like I just
think you know how boys like they do
stupid [__] right like we get we get
into we get curious so like we might be
breaking sticks and it turns into like
breaking something else right right and
then just one thing LEDs to another
breaking in entery yeah breaking a
[__] whatever me and my cousin used
to uh go into like empty Apartments
really like we were like little kids all
right we would go into like empty
apartments that weren that were vacant
and we' just be like acting like it was
our place hey he wants a waffles no no
no so what we do we play house that's me
and my sister my cousin and my brother
we go and play house and then like we go
to the freezer take out the Ice uh trays
in there fill them up with the water put
the ice tray in there act like that's
our food and [__] like that that's the
cutest thing I've ever heard of in my
life that's the cutest b& I've ever
heard what a puzzle for the person that
comes in there
after like who put those yeah and
they're trying to make sense of every
little thing like the ice tray turned
over
why it's like bro none of that means
anything yeah I think like it was things
like that like we would get into the
storage space of the church and just
start looking at pictures yeah you're
just curious that's true yeah but this
is why we get along Joe Joe I did the
same exact thing same exact thing but I
think like it was too much and I I
probably was an absolute Menace like cuz
it was multiple kids where it was like
oh they're parents and my mom just goes
yeah I don't like parents that judge
children she goes like we should get
together as parents and she goes like
it's like yeah and then she and then I
don't know but she said the stuff that I
did was like socially unacceptable it
wasn't wrong wrong and then it it was
like [__] like like I don't know like
I'll be like there's a party right and
like I'll get on top of the table and
start dancing or some [__] and then
she's like laughing and busting up while
other parents are like oh that's like
inappropriate not supposed to put your
feet
on dude I would love to see some home
video Joe get him off the pool right now
yeah I feel like he's a wild thing he is
he was yeah yeah so I think like that
was most of it the other one would be
like I wouldn't be picked when we play
games for sports for sports oh yeah cuz
then all types of sports even soccer I
got picked for uh for football they they
would I would play for soccer but
basketball that's a
tough that's a tough
sport that's a close SP cuz they just
look at you and be like no he can't ball
yeah I would be the kid that would that
would make it for the other team and
think I scored yeah cuz I just don't
know how to play I just don't know and
no one taught me how to play basketball
so I would ruin the game so it makes
sense right like just like elementary
school and then like I would like push
somebody take their ball and run with it
and then like try to make it no dribbles
no so I'm not playing that's why they're
not picking me that kid that's so
stressful there was always that kid you
ruined it for the rest of them right so
it's like good reason why I wasn't
chosen yeah cuz I'm ruining the game but
in my stupid young head I'm like I never
get picked you know what I mean like I'm
like later on I'm like oh yeah duh like
I did stupid
[__] mine's like a combination of yours
when I was younger didn't get picked
especially for sports but I was like I
was pretty decent seemed pretty athletic
though yeah what I'm saying is like I
was pretty decent so I think they just
kind of just judge judge me a girl oh is
that like among mostly boys or girls um
just just in school like in elementary
school and stuff just wouldn't get
picked was it all like girls and for
like group projects too also wouldn't
get picked until like I did the group
project and then I'd be the only one
doing all the work and then I got picked
a lot oh yeah because you're the one
doing all the work yeah and then I'm
also in combination of yours as well in
high school I just would move around
from group to group I'd have like a few
close friends um so I I don't think I
ever had like my own community in my
close circle of friends so I naturally
was excluded from a lot of things were
you always a taller kid compared to
other girls or did you like grow at a
certain like Point um I think I got a
little bit taller in high school in high
school yeah but I was always
like pretty decently sized I don't think
I ever remember being like short um but
I felt short in my family cuz my
brother's super tall my mom's really
tall my dad was decently tall gotcha but
did you when you were like a did you
have a pretty girl rep growing up no I
was a ugly duckling cuz that's an easy
reason yeah I was definitely I was like
super
skinny um like very
yeah listen no no Talent no potential
till very late I want know that yeah
none of that so when when did the
potential develop the potential
developed much
later much later yeah damn and I was
like especially when I was younger too
and I wasn't getting picked I was really
shy so I think I was kind of excluded
from that too because I wasn't vocal oh
they're just like that random girl
standing there like that yeah who knows
her would they make fun of your name
throwing up were kids make fun of your
name um no they just make fun of how
white I was how white yeah how white
were they hey yeah were they white
you're I mean you're pretty I mean now
but like back then I was pretty [__]
pale like I was almost translucent
thator
trans AEL I was translucent and really
skinny so you know I turned to the side
and like I really disappear damn so wait
so it's white kids making fun of you on
how white you are yeah pretty much
that's tough that's real white onwhite
kid crime white and white
crime yeah happens everywhere dude
happens everywhere I always thought if
you were lighter than they would give
you props nice
K keep it up you're really whing out of
the
St here cover yourself up that's
fantastic yeah talk up to you white kids
talking to each other remarkable
colen Stellar dude to go excellent
work take us to the top
colen I knew you were going to be the
one I knew you going to be the one
but you still can't play with
us I it take us to the
top maxing it out
K come back with more Talent or maybe
nobody picked me because they didn't
know how to say my name that might be it
too say they were trying to pick you
they're
like I say clean like if I'm going to
clean something just emphasize the
Callen which one would you prefer clean
or Colleen I would prefer Colleen
kin you like clean clean clean clean
that's like a way Chinese person
name Yeah clean that's pretty good I
think like for me I didn't feel excluded
much growing up until I had to go to
summer school because I went to the same
exact school so you knew everyone from
kindergarten yeah cuz I went from
kindergarten all the way to senior high
school was the same people in every
class oh you were SJ the whole time no I
was at a before but in Adventist Union
School in Bellflower it was me and like
nine other kids kindergarten age five
and those same kids stayed in the same
class with me all the way up so I had
them in high school too so I never had
the feeling of like oh I don't know
anybody I got to like you know I'm the
I'm the fresh fish but then I I had to
go to summer school and take algebra at
Don Bosco Tech and [__] that school yeah
I heard no one likes that place that's
that all boy School everyone makes fun
of them cuz it's an all boy Catholic
school where all the dudes like it's
like in cell heaven really yeah because
they're all boys they have no girls but
then in the summer they let it be coed
so now you have these boys that have
never seen a girl for the whole year
finally and they're all acting like
idiots you know what I mean that's good
though kind of funny good energy that's
way to stand out
too and the school I think knew that I
wasn't uh Catholic and then that's when
the faculty would just [__] on me all
the time really yeah because I came in
there and I was like uh hey look at this
Saturday worshipper yeah you go to
church on Saturday we a loser you know
you're not going to heaven right they
were just like meaner to me like I never
I never and and plus like you know SGA
The Faculty is so nice to you they
really like treat you like family and
then I went there my first day I still
had like blonde spiky hair cuz this is
1999 or something and then uh the uh the
dean of discipline uh takes me into the
he's like uh come with me and then we I
thought they were going to give me like
a welcome or something he pulls me into
the uh like one of the faculty offices
where they're all like having coffee or
like L just sitting around just like we
are and he stands me up and he goes hey
guys you think a you think a kid with
hair like this makes Stellar grades and
they all just started laughing whoa
that's a different time bro and you
should you should have been like
actually I make 4.0 with this and
that he was right with the stereotype
what what what did you say right after
that nothing I was shocked I was just I
thought I really thought they were going
to go hey we got a new kid like we're
all going to welcome him but no it was
like literally opposite what the [__]
and then all of them are like they all
were just like [__] up like it was
like I was catching them you know when
you catch your teachers when it's not
teacher time and then they act a little
different but this was like the bad side
of that so they were all just Clowning
knowing that nothing's going to happen
so they were like making fun of you yeah
they were all making fun of me yeah
because Don Bosco Tech you [__]
yeah [__] that school and plus like
after that I thought I could make
friends instantly with the other kids
and then I get in that classroom and
it's like half Vietnamese watching oh my
God they're all gangsters and that's the
first time I ever been called a dirty
Filipino no way I never heard that like
I never put those two things together
cuz Filipino people have been in my
class my whole life and then these dudes
were like oh you dirty Filipino and I
feel like Filipino people are never like
that yeah like I said what like that's a
wild take
did you ever tell your parents about
that right after no I wasn't talking to
them like that back then but I was
telling my friends from my my school and
what did they say and they just didn't
know what to think of it cuz they
they've never been to in an environment
like that like we were we were sheltered
we were all like 7 Day atist good like
kids yeah we don't even like cuss at
each other and then now like I got to
deal with all these like different
ecosystems of it's funny how you going
to Don Bosco and it's like this Catholic
school but it's more like juvenile hall
it is yeah it it really was and I think
like all because it's all boys they're
so desperate to like be in the pecking
order they're all desperate to like move
up cuz all you're competing against is
other guys and then when you throw girls
in the mix now they have to compete in
front of somebody so it was like really
weird plus my ex that just broke up with
me right before Summer started started
going there so she was there too I had
to listen to all the guys like gawking
about her and she acted like she didn't
know me cuz now she's getting L
attention I was like this sucks bro
those that Those Years bro are tough but
get old and fat they're tough no she's
still decent she's still she's Korean
she don't okay we got to get her fat
somehow yeah somehow keep her in
America we got to get her
fat I like how that's the ultimate
[Music]
Revenge
pap